you mentioned that you used to do
research at night and go to bed at like
6 a.m or 7 a.m
i still do that
often
um
what sleep schedules have you tried to
make for a productive and happy life
like is there
um is there some interesting wild
sleeping patterns that you engage that
you found that works really well for you
i tried at some point decreasing number
of hours of sleep like a gradually
like a half an hour every few days less
you know i was hoping to just save time
yeah that clearly didn't work for me
like at some point there's like a phase
shift and
i felt tired all the
time you know there was a time that i
used to work during the nights the nice
thing about the nights is that no one
disturbs you and
even i remember
when i was
meeting for the first time with greg
brockman he's cto and chairman of openai
our meeting was scheduled till 5 pm
and i overstepped for the meeting
overslept for the meeting yeah 5 pm yeah
now you sound like me that's hilarious
okay yeah and uh at the moment in some
sense uh
my sleeping schedule also has to do with
the fact that i'm
interacting with people
i sleep without an alarm
so
so yeah the the team thing you mentioned
extrovert thing because
most humans operate during a certain set
of hours
you're forced to then operate at the
same set of hours
but
i'm not quite there yet
i found a lot of joy just like you said
working through the night
because it's quiet
because the world doesn't disturb you
and there's some aspect
counter to everything you're saying
there's some joyful aspect to sleeping
through the mess of the day
because people are having meetings and
sending emails and there's drama
meetings
i can sleep through all the meetings you
know i have meetings every day and they
prevent me from having sufficient amount
of time for
focus work
and
then
i modified my calendar and i said that
i'm out of office wednesday thursday and
friday every day and i'm having meetings
only monday and tuesday
and that vastly
positively influenced my mood that i
have literally like had three days for
fully focused work yeah
so there's better solutions to this
problem than staying awake all night
you